Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie split but  what went wrong et has an inside look at  the pair's breakup after more than ten  years together I'm very privileged that  he felt safe to to be that way with me a  source tells ET the relationship had  actually been in trouble for some time  quote this was a long time coming they  have been fighting for the last year  they haven't slept in the same bed for a  big chunk of that our source says when  the pair was in New York together in  November they had separate hotel rooms  and operated on their own individual  schedules et has also spoken with  Angelina Jolie's father actor Jon Voight  who tells us he will be there to support  his daughter and grandchildren quote it  must have been pretty severe for this to  happen I don't know much yet but plan on  speaking to her and the kids very soon  you